depuis le rachat en 2018 de west fil par
unibail rodamco pour plus de 20
milliards d'euros
la marque s'affiche sur les murs du
centre commercial vélizy 2 depuis
septembre 2019 avec un changement
stratégique de nouvelles possibilités et
une augmentation de la fréquentation
wasyl c'est vraiment le standard le
label mondialement reconnu par les
grandes marques internationales et nous
serons mieux en mesure de faire venir
des marques très iconique
même situation pour parly 2 avec qwest
field le centre commercial au 184
boutiques et 15 restaurants attire des
nouvelles marques
c'est le cas d'albert combi and fitch
qui implante son deuxième magasin en
france westfield à parly 2 et est un
lieu de shopping une référence de
shopping de l'ouest parisien
mais également et surtout un lieu de vie
un lieu de rencontre des changes
et pour cela le visiteur est au coeur de
cette de cette problématique
nous travaillons sur sur une
programmation événementielle et
d'animation assez assez inédite
tout ça pour que le client en fait est
une une expérience très développée très
riche lorsqu'il vient ici faire son
shopping
le déploiement de la marque l'ouest fils
se poursuivra en 2020 et 2022 dans les
centres appartenant au groupe
unibail-rodamco notamment en europe aux
pays bas et en allemagne